[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya une courbe qui va s'afficher
derrière moi est ce que vous savez à
quoi correspond cette image
cette image c'est le déficit public des
hôpitaux entre 2012 et 2017
le déficit public était 200 millions en
2012 de 470 millions en 2016 et d'un
milliard cinq en 2017
il a été multiplié par 7 en 5 ans et par
trois sur la dernière année
ça vous inquiète il ya 9 français sur 10
qui pense que l'hôpital est en danger il
ya 70% des personnes qui pensent qu'il
ya un problème de personnel le manque de
personnel les embauches sont gelées
le point de rupture est proche
les urgences débordent
qu'est ce qu'on fait et ben moi je
m'appelle goulven or si je suis pas
professionnel de santé
je suis ingénieur informaticien mais
tous les jours j'essaie de travailler à
résoudre une partie de cette
problématique
il ya trois ans j'ai un ami pharmacien
hospitalier qui est venu me voir en me
disant qu'il y avait un problème de
médicaments qui arrivés à péremption
dans l'hôpital c'est des médicaments
souvent très onéreux les anticancéreux
anti hépatite c qui valent souvent 8000
euros le traitement la semaine et quand
le patient est transférée d'hôpital ne
supporte pas le traitement ou décède et
qui a pas d'autres patients avec la même
pathologie mais mal médicaments rassure
étagères et risquent d'être perdus donc
ce qui fait dans ces cas là ces qui
prend son téléphone
il appelle les trois quatre cinq
hôpitaux quand il a le temps de le faire
qui sont autour de chez lui pour savoir
s'il ya pas une capacité de reprise
et s'il n'y a pas de capacité de reprise
le médicament est perdue parce qu'il
faut savoir que les hôpitaux les
systèmes d'information des hôpitaux sont
pas interconnectés entre eux le moyen de
communication que souvent
plus utilisés entre hôpitaux c'est
encore le fax on est en 2018 on parle
bien du fax entre hôpitaux on a cherché
des chiffres sur le sujet sur ses pertes
de médicaments il ya 50 millions d'euros
de médicaments et dispositifs médicaux
qui sont perdus chaque année en france
alors on a décidé de monter une plate
forme qui permet tout simplement aux
pharmaciens hospitaliers de mettre à
disposition ces médicaments qui arrivent
à péremption
que ce soit au niveau régional au niveau
national pour maximiser ses capacités de
reprise et une fois qu'on avait
connecter ces hôpitaux on a connecté 200
hôpitaux on s'est dit à d'autres
problématiques à régler c'est pareil par
exemple quand il ya une préparation de
médicaments qui fait d'un hôpital à
l'autre les commandes se font par fax
tiens d'ailleurs est ce que vous savez
dans les quatre plans blancs alerte
attentats quand il faut compter les
médicaments vitaux comment ça se passe
et bien encore une fois c'est un
pharmacien de l'hôpital qui prend le
téléphone qui appelle ses collègues des
autres hôpitaux qui va noter sur une
feuille l'état des stocks un par un
alors qu'avec des plateformes modernes
qu'on produit bien ça se fait dans plein
de domaines on est capable de remonter
en temps réel se connecter sur la
gestion de stock des hôpitaux est
remonté tout le stock d'une région c'est
pareil il ya de plus en plus
malheureusement de rupture
d'approvisionnement de produits des
laboratoires qui sont pas capables de
fournir
il ya des alertes qui sont faites par l'
agence du médicament mais au sein de
l'hôpital l'organisation pour savoir
quel est le médicament de remplacement
quels sont les cliniciens consulter
qu'elles sont l'état des stocks restants
ça se fait souvent sur des fichiers
excel et c'est pas partager avec les
autres hôpitaux
le point clé c'est de réussir à faire
gagner du temps
ces professionnels de santé qui n'ont
déjà pas beaucoup que l'information leur
arrive tout de suite en temps réel c'est
ça l'avancé des nouvelles technologies
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous avez vu
ce matin il ya même des start up
c'est ainsi qu'ils vont mettre des
bracelets aux patients pour les
géolocaliser dans l'hôpital parce que
souvent c'est une perte de temps pour
les chirurgiens d'aller retrouver leurs
patients pour les chirurgies et
maintenant ils sont capables dégâts le
patient est là lebron et on revient de
temps il ya une deuxième problématique
qui est lié c'est le problème des
changes d'information d'en parler de
l'hôpital à hôpital mais ça peut être
aussi bien des professionnels de ville
vers l'hôpital et tout ça ça peut
apporter des engorgements l'urgence des
dépenses inutiles
je vais vous prendre un exemple très
personnel j'ai été papa ya quelques
semaines
merci et on est parti aux urgences de la
maternité avec ma femme très rapidement
n'avait pas pris de dossiers papier
imaginez bien et quand on est arrivé à
l'hôpital la sage-femme à dia j'ai pas
vous donner
je n'ai pas accès à vous donner on est
en 2018 elles avaient pas accès ne m'est
donnée de centrales et donner ma femme
surtout données de santé alors que tout
le suivi de la grossesse s'était passé à
l'étagé au dessus avec le gynécologue et
je lui ai fait perdre un quart d'heure
un quart d'heure à une sage femme pour
me connecter sur son ordinateur sur sa
boîte mail allez jo ma boite mail à les
transférer les informations de santé
pour qu'elles y aient accès encore une
fois c'est une aberration en 2018 et
puis là on parle pas de big data on
parle pas de blocs chaîne d'intelligence
artificielle on parle juste de
transmettre de l'information de santé
d'un étage à un autre d'un hôpital à un
autre ou de la ville vers l'hôpital on a
travaillé avec les hôpitaux bretons
justement pour les connecter encore une
fois à travers le plâtre des plateformes
pour faciliter ces échanges
d'informations je vais reprendre encore
un exemple sur le médicament de
problèmes qui veut avoir voulait
peut-être entendu ces derniers temps et
un collectif de bon usage du médicament
qui en parle sur votre prise de
médicaments les effets indésirables qui
peuvent en atelier
ça correspond à plus d'un million de
journées d'hospitalisation un million
journées d'hospitalisation ça concerne
130 mille patients par an et ça provoque
plus de dix mille décès par an on parle
bien de presque trois fois le nombre de
morts sur les routes
si on prend une personne âgée il ya 20 %
des plus de 65 ans qui prennent cette
traitement différent et quand cette
personne âgée elle arrive à l'hôpital
aux urgences avait vu par un médecin
urgentiste qui va lui faire une
prescription d'entrée mais il aura pas
une connaissance complète sur sa prise
de médicaments sur son auto médication
sur ces allergies non qu'il va avoir une
rupture d'information qui peut entraîner
une interaction médicamenteuse qui va
pas recréer une hospitalisation qui peut
lui poser des problèmes de santé qui va
coûter encore une fois très cher la
haute autorité de santé recommande de
faire des bilans de médication les
villans de médication c'est récupérer
l'information de la ville du médecin
traitant
la pharmacie d'officine des spécialistes
pour avoir l'exhaustivité de la prise de
médicaments du patient mais encore une
fois comment ça se passe emma la
formation de la rive de la ville la
plupart du temps elle va arriver par fax
ou par téléphone
on va remplir des tableaux excel et
faire ce bilan de médication aujourd'hui
ça prend une heure par passion donc il
ya très peu de patients qui sont suivies
encore une fois avec une plateforme
moderne on peut se synchroniser aux
différents logiciels de prescription
d'information du patient de l'hôpital
pour récupérer directement ces
informations on va pouvoir se connecter
sur les logiciels de la ville
encore une fois par des moyens
numériques récupérer en temps réel
sainte informations pour que les
professionnels de santé puissent avoir
un tableau dans général qui puisse aller
avec une tablette dans la chambre du
patient le questionner remplir les
informations et encore une fois ça
viennent remplir toutes ses sources
d'informations différentes
là dessus il ya déjà des tuyaux qui
existe
vous avez un dossier médical partagé
il va être en place depuis 10 15 ans il
ya des dossiers pharmaceutiques quand
vous allez à la pharmacie les
professionnels de santé ont des
messageries sécurité de santé pour
transférer l'information
mais tout cet ensemble manque
cruellement de connexion et c'est pas
connecté avec les systèmes d'information
de l'hôpital est donc aujourd'hui il ya
un problème vous pour avoir toutes ces
informations en temps réel
mais demain on va pouvoir avoir un bilan
de médication numérique qui arrivera en
temps réel tran sortira de l'hôpital
c'est nos informations santé vont
pouvoir arriver automatiquement vers le
médecin traitant vers la pharmacie aux
idées vous conseiller je vais prendre
les derniers chiffres sur le sujet est
ce que vous savez quand vous diagnostic
malheureusement un cancer à l'hôpital
combien de médecins traitants une
information complète et ben y'a que 31 %
des médecins traitants
quand l'information complète sur le
cancer de leurs patients dans les quatre
mois qui suivent l'hospitalisation
ça montre à quel point il ya besoin de
fluidifier cette information santé
j'imaginais bien si le médecin traitant
a pas l'information déjà vous mais c'est
un traitant vous le connaissez vous avez
besoin de lui en parler lui il va avoir
du mal à vous rediriger vers un
spécialiste
donc ça peut encore une fois il va vous
ramener vers les urgences ça les
horaires est engorgé encore une fois il
ya besoin le fluidifier cette
information alors bien sûr le numérique
c'est pas une baguette magique ça va pas
régler tous les problèmes de l'hôpital
on est bien d'accord
et puis en plus il ya un défi avec vos
données de santé de les sécuriser
2 les protégés de contrôler l'accès pour
pâques et de sa pose de problème
supplémentaire mais il ya besoin de
cette information et puis là la
révolution numérique est en marche en
l'hôpital a souvent 10 15 ans de retard
sur le sujet n'est en train de s'y
mettre les toutes les sociétés
il ya plein de jeunes sociétés qui
élaborent plus en plus de projets pour
le suivi des patients
donc il ya un grand espoir pour les
décennies à venir d'améliorer vos
informations de santé
il ya un professionnel de santé
c'est un pharmacien qui m'a dit une fois
mais vous n'êtes pas un super héros on
vous a pas attendu pour trouver des
solutions
bien évidemment ces pannes ou les super
héros et super héros c'est les
professionnels de santé qui travaillent
tous les jours auprès des patients mais
nous on essaye juste de leur portait une
cape une cape numérique pour augmenter
leurs super pouvoirs pour qu'ils aient
accès en temps réel à toutes les
informations parce que vous savez moi ce
que j'aimerais c'est que pour théodore
pour anatole ah oui je vous ai pas dit
théodore et anatole sur mes enfants
c'est que quand ils iront à la maternité
avec leurs femmes en 2038 ou en 2048
c'est toutes leurs informations de santé
soient accessibles en un instant que ce
soit dans le même hôpital dans la même
région
partout dans le monde grâce à cette
métamorphose et xxl de l'hôpital
numérique de demain
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]